[Music]
hello and welcome back to the endgame
class today I wanted to kind of continue
the theme of tonight and go over some
very fun and games from the 2016 World
Championship match this match of course
between Magnus Carlsen and Sergei
Kuryakin now myself included there are a
lot of doubters in Sergei cariocans
ability after he won the candidates to
really challenge the world champion but
a lot of fun games ended up coming out
of this World Championship and a lot of
really interesting end games of course
Sergei was known as one of the world's
greatest defenders he still is to this
day one of the world's greatest
defenders in fact I believe here in
himself a very fun nickname the Minister
of Defense in this world championship
match so the first end game I wanted to
look at today from this match is one
where Magnus Carlsen was trying his
utmost to break down this Minister of
Defense so we'll see
Sergei Kuryakin trying to handle a worse
end game and how he ended up holding it
to a draw against the world champion so
let's just jump into it of course this
is an endgame class so we don't care so
much about the opening it was a royal
apes' as I'm sure many of you are
familiar this none of this matters this
is all stupid and after these pieces get
traded we find ourselves in a little bit
of an end game here so Bishop takes d5
Bishop g5 was Sergei cariocans try now
kingi six h4 King h5 from Magnus Knight
h3 bishop a f7 Bishop e7 and after the
bishop takes h4 and Bishop takes d6 we
arrived at the first kind of position I
want to talk about in this endgame so of
course very clearly here Magnus Carlsen
is on the better end of this endgame and
there are a few reasons for that the
first reason is the bishop pair tends to
be quite strong in the endgame the
bishops work together to control large
swaths of the board
to help support past ponds to help stop
opponents past ponds and that is
definitely going to be the case here but
actually the more relevant advantage for
Magnus is the fact that he has these two
ponds against this one over here on the
Kings side this is how Magnus is going
to try to win the game using these two
ponds against white single pond on g2 in
the meantime it's not as though white is
down upon me of course has this extra be
pond but pretty clearly this pawn is not
going to be very relevant for a long
long time this one pawn on c4 of course
is in great position it stops both of
these white ponds with just its own
power so kind of one pond combating two
on the Queen side and so effectively
it's almost as though Magnus Carlsen is
up a clean pond here in the game Magnus
chose the move Bishop d8 kind of
removing this Bishop out of the way of
the King and Sergei plays a very nice
move King G King ytube getting the King
into the game centralizing the King now
g5 comes on the board for Magnus Sergey
tries to centralize the night with
Knight f2 and Magnus plays the move king
g6 just bringing the King back into
position so with the white player here
try and come up with some way to try and
hold this position sir case next move is
pretty key I think towards the the
drawing attempt so let's see what you
guys can come up with here what should
Sergei try in order to slow down these
pawns on the King side and try and hold
the draw here
what can be done I'll allow the chat
sometime to come up with some ideas here
so Aakash in fact does have the correct
move the next move for Sergei is this
move g4 and this is the move that allows
white to get black you know one or two
things to think about in this end game
with g4 white may always be threatening
to take on f5 it's certainly something
that Magnus is going to have to have in
mind for the rest of this game and with
g4 it's also kind of tempting Magnus to
play the move of f4 and in the game and
this is kind of what happens
Magnus plays the move Bishop d6 now sir
get it plays be very very accurate
Bishop e5 the point of this move being
in some cases we're gonna need to drop
this Bishop back to d4 to avoid any
nastiness
so a5 played in the game by Magnus now
91 and very quickly actually not super
quickly but but relatively quickly in
the game Magnus committed to this next
move f4 and some of you may have heard a
famous quote by Magnus Carlsen saying
you know he doesn't believe in
fortresses and I think this quote
actually originates from the the
postgame press conference of this game
right here during this World
Championship match the exact quote that
I could find was Magnus says he's not a
big believer in fortresses so after the
move f4 he thought he would have some
way to break down White's position here
to break in to the so-called fortress
and to force a win for the black pieces
now this is a really interesting end
game and the players in the game itself
really explored the various options
after f4 so we will definitely get to f4
and why it ends up actually just being a
draw
how Wyatt managed to hold this seemingly
lost looking position to a draw but when
I was going over this game in the
postgame press conference you know it
was kind of agreed by by everyone
involved yeah okay maybe you have four
throw
the win but black is is probably just of
course winning here but the two bishops
and and these two pawns in the Kings
side and so I strove to to test that
claim now if you were following the
twitch stream earlier on we were going
over some variations there as well but I
think the key line here for black is to
play the move Bishop takes east six and
this is the move that really challenges
white the most I think I did a lot of
analysis with the help of computers here
to try and figure out if this is in fact
a win for black or not so I want to
challenge you guys see what you think is
the best way to try and hold this
position for white you have a few
options here I'll afford you G takes up
five is definitely one option and it's
actually stock fish's first option if
you ask it you can also just sit on the
position with something like Knight f2
or find some other way to pass with a
move like Bishop d4 so you can take or
you can kind of pass with my def to
remove like Bishop d4 King f3 I don't
think it's a very good pass because then
this move comes with check as well as
this move comes with check this King's
pretty happy on me too so what do you
guys think between those options what do
you guys think could be the loot the
move the line what's the line
Jon Gosselin suggests the move a 4 a 4
might just be a little bit too premature
here a 4 is going to be a relevance
resource for white in these positions
but if you do play a 4 now the fact of
the matter is now Magnus's move that you
played in the game f4 really gains in
power because you get a similar position
to the game but this pawn on a 4 is just
going to drop off the board not not so
easy not so easy
so William Oh Joe uh says the move
Bishop d4 I'm a doc schemer it says
Knight f2 is great
fair enough fair enough so I think the
problem with Bishop d4 is that the move
Bishop c7 is taking away a more relevant
diagonal from white now whenever
eventually this Jeep on becomes past the
g3 square is firmly in blacks control
and that's gonna be really really
relevant as we'll see in the main lines
here
somebody somewhere says prevent f4 take
it so this is actually stock fish's
first option I think unless you allow it
to sit and think for a really really
long time and this is one that I
actually did manage to analyze to a win
for black this one is simply affording
black a little bit too much with the
king so for example and move King takes
that five could come on the board and
now it's not so easy to kind of pass for
white this bishops attacked so well
let's say the move Bishop b8 comes on
the board well now there are really a
variety of options here for black and I
think all of them really kind of
maintain the win what's important is
that you don't play the move g4 after g4
white more or less is easily drawing so
let's say black plays the move a4
instead this is a nice move because it
doesn't really give up much from black
and definitely never allows white to do
the annoying a4 and pick up this pawn on
f5 it's a move intended just to free up
this bishop for example if black is a
little bit nonchalant and plays the move
Bishop c5 instead maybe the idea of a4
is something that's white could consider
the idea of Bishop c7 to follow to pick
up a 5 so a4 I think is a nice move from
black and after let's say white simply
passes again what do you think the
winning idea for black is going to be
here see if you guys at home can find
the winning maneuver for black why is
white drawing if black plays g4 well
Alex
after you find the winning maneuver here
it'll make a little bit more sense then
what's the winning maneuver for black
let's see if you guys at home can figure
this one out
kingi for king g4 is an interesting idea
I don't think it's enough though I don't
think it's enough with King G for you're
kind of running a little bit too far
maybe move a 93 check could come on the
board and if you keep running up the
board let's see here maybe Knight f1
with some ideas of blockading here so
not not King g4 not King g4 maybe King
g4 still maintains a win but it's it's
not really enough it's not really enough
so this person with the language I
cannot pronounce does in fact have the
correct maneuver the maneuver here for
black twin is actually the slightly
counterintuitive Bishop f7 this is why
black doesn't want to play g4 with
Bishop f7 we are using this diagonal to
our advantage and this is what really
highlights that the fact that the
bishops are too powerful they need these
open diagonals in order to win 93 check
is really the only try for white and now
this King simply steps in to e4 just
like king g4 except better because it's
efore now for example Knight c2 is
trying to draw but things like Bishop h5
check are going to be enough to win this
game this King has to step 2 f1 now and
we've granted our King entry into the
position for example night before check
King d2 and this pawn on g5 really comes
in handy guarding some of these key dark
squares now the game continued many ways
but let's just say 95 Bishop a7 keeping
an eye on b6 King g2 for example King c1
and the black king is going to clean up
over here on the Queen's side and it
should just be a pretty trivial win from
this point for for black for example
Knight f6 Bishop d1 this should be for
for example King takes b2 and with this
extra G pawn and with all of these Kings
side pawns falling now black is just
within the game I'm gonna call this line
here so what was important in this line
the importance is the opening of this
diagonal bringing this Bishop to h5 in
order to win this game now a brief point
to make about this endgame of course if
black or white simply passes with Bishop
b8 we are totally totally happy taking
off this knight black is striving to
achieve an endgame with bishops of the
same color now conversely white of
course is hoping to achieve an endgame
with bishops of opposite color so of
course bishops of opposite colors those
end games tend to be more drawn
Bishop's of the same color much much
much easier to win because the bishops
can kind of challenge each other to
force each other off of their defensive
blockades so okay so that is why in this
line
Bishop e8 the really only the move the
only move that I think throws away the
wind entirely is the move g4 because
after g4 you don't have this idea of
Bishop f7 you don't even have ideas of
king g4 and it's much much more
difficult to shake this King loose from
this e2 square where it is firmly
blockaded so because of that this is why
the move G takes f v is very simply
losing for white it opens up this
diagonal and black can use this diagonal
effectively to end up winning the game
so it stands to reason why white
shouldn't take on the f5 square in fact
the move Knight f2 is the line that I
struggled the most with and trying to
win so Knight f2 and if you pass white
is simply going to pass as well you know
and eventually you're gonna have to
commit to a move like f4 which is a draw
as we'll see in the game or eventually
we'll have to commit to F takes G for
anyways and so I think this is the best
opportunity for black to go ahead and
take on g4 so F takes G 4 and now
hopefully with the lines you've just
seen you'll be able to pick out White's
best move here White's only move really
to make sure this draw is still worth
fighting for
so find the only move here for white to
kind of maintain the fortress
so if you play King you for William I
think you're just gonna get it with 9f
to check and you'll have to repeat with
a move like King f5 or King d5 even so
yeah in that previous line Knight F to
check it's always gonna be right
response to to king f4 so why are you
thinking about this there's a question
for me here
what is the player that helped me
improve the most by studying his games
I really can't pick out one player in
particular just it's kind of improving
at chess is always going to be just some
huge combination of various sources
combined together it's hard to pinpoint
one specific thing Wow everybody seems
to agree that it's Knight h1 except now
I'm a Doc's gamer in tt0 as well as Todd
who all have the correct answer in
Bishop g3 of course the point here
you can't allow black to play g3
sacrificing the pawn because then black
would open up this diagonal once again
and achieve more or less the same type
of winning position if you do go for
nine h1 well the problem is if I think
g3 is going to be good enough here
g3 Knight takes g3 Bishop g4 check King
II 1 and ok I guess maybe you have a
point with this you're still keeping
this king out but maybe I can do
slightly better with the move King h5
and now all of a sudden if you play
Bishop g3 here it's not quite so easy
for example Bishop d2 check and life is
going to be difficult for you life is
going to be very difficult for you with
this Bishop on f3 so much better is to
play Bishop e3 immediately just
blockading this pawn making sure this
diagonal doesn't open up making sure
black has to come up with some other
creative ways to try to win now if your
name is Magnus Carlsen congratulations
you're the world champion of chess
however you have quite a difficult
challenge on your plate here you have to
find some way to come up with winning
attempts winning chances in this
position after the move Bishop g3
so I'd like you guys at home to take a
few moments try and find some winning
attempts for black from this position
try and find some way to break in to the
opponent's fortress created how can you
break through
how can you break through here
okay
so teaching zeroes is giving me one move
Bishop d5 which is one move Bishop d5
but I need a winning plan talking about
winning plans here so everybody's just
giving me one move exchange the bishop
for the night so this is the one thing
you really can't do here with black if
you ever trade this bishop for the
knight you end up and what I was talking
about earlier with an endgame with
bishops of opposite colors and since
actually a very very routine draw now
for white these bishops can't ever
interact with each other and so black is
simply going to place in this King onto
g3 and you can never remove this king
from g3 in the meantime white is going
to defend both of these pawns with a
bishop on b4 and it's simply impossible
to make progress here so you absolutely
cannot trade this bishop for this Knight
running the King it to the Queen side so
that is a very viable winning plan King
f4 or a king f5 I assume and Bishop d8
to f6 to e5 this is another viable
winning plan these are things worth
thinking about
so with this winning plan you are trying
to get the Bishop off of g3 if you can
break this blockade on g3 then hopefully
you can push these pawns forward and
invade with your king
it's a a perfectly viable way to play
the position any other winning plans so
Bishop d5 to f3 was another winning plan
offered up so these are three winning
plans
trade dark-squared bishop s' and
penetrate with the king from age 4 so
yeah trading with r squared bishops is a
viable plan
so why don't we analyze these plans one
by one the simplest plan to analyze is
bringing the king to the Queen side I
think this is the most natural way
actually of for black to play if black
can get this King to the Queen side then
the pawns on the Kings side will stretch
the pieces to thin your threats on both
sides of the board and black wins the
game and it'd be really really great if
that in fact did win
unfortunately white has a very creative
way to hold the game and just barely
white is going to be able to hold a draw
here so 91 is the best way for white to
pass keeping all the options open
kingi for now really the only way for
white to pass is night off to once again
offering up this trade because this is
always going to be an easy draw with
opposite color bishops now King d5 is
the natural way for black to continue
aiming for the Queen side and who now
thinks they can find the drawing idea
for white here
it's pretty counterintuitive actually
I'll be impressed if anybody at home can
come up with a draw here for white I'll
be so kind as to tell you why it's next
or a blacks next four moves black is
going here then black is going here then
black is going here and if you let them
blacks going here and here this is the
idea that you have to beat now how can
you stop this idea
how can you stop this idea
or Bishop d7 to a4 this Bishop does
nothing if it's if it's in these squares
there's nothing for it to attack
okay William is saying Bishop d6 later
I'm an ox cameras saying 91 to 93 I
don't know how that stops my plan
91 King C 693 king b5 I'm still coming
in tell me how it stops my plan March
the King to see to okay that's one try
and stopping King b3 but my question for
you is is how are you meeting Bishop a5
check after king king to see - I'm not
so sure
rounding the King to c1 similar question
what are you doing against Bishop III
check there okay some people now are
saying a4 but of course after Bishop d7
this pawn is not that pawn this pawn is
going to be dropping off the board and
then I can simply reroute the bishop
back and continue about my business
who has the drawing idea can anyone find
it can anyone find it so I guess I'll
throw this one on the board if you want
to go this way just for example let's
entertain this idea
you bring the king to see to then I
assume you're just going to start
passing again King a four-night of two
you're running into these checks these
checks evict you and then I get to take
on b2 so the king is not enough the king
is not enough King to a two and he is
safe okay let's try it
King to a to say a king here King a -
okay let's say now fish about five now I
guess it's time for you to start passing
King and one maybe King any one allows
King b3 so maybe you don't want to do
that 91 instead but now Bishop c2 Knight
f2 and okay maybe not maybe not actually
let me think let me think
use some brain power here hmm
okay I've got it maybe Bishop c5 Knight
f2 Bishop e3 91 and Bishop f4 and with
your king all the way over on this a
file it's going to be quite tough for
you to deal with these threats to the
Kings side
I think blacks pawns are just queening
by force so King over to a to a nice
idea but it's not quite enough not quite
enough so how do you stop the black king
invasion I I don't think you guys are
gonna find this one it's a pretty crazy
idea the idea of course is 91 some of
you said the first move but I don't
think you had the idea King you see 693
king b5 Knight see - King a4 and then
believe it or not
94 is enough for white to hold the drum
you definitely wouldn't think so
at first glance but in fact white is
just barely holding a draw after
efore of course the idea for white is
you prevent this king from coming into
b3 the only way to attempt to stop it
or to break through with black now is to
play Bishop takes d4 in fact if you
don't play Bishop takes d4 your king has
just totally stalemated over here
difficult to make progress like that so
Bishop takes d4 C takes d4 and then
there's simply no way for black to win
this opposite colored Bishop endgame
once again white finds solace in the
bishops of opposite colors and this
endgame is going to be a draw who can
find the best attempt however who can
find the best attempt for black here the
best attempt to try and win this
position
who has the best attempts
King b3 so King me through is the most
natural attempt the issue is d5 hits
this Bishop Bishop takes d5 and now
Bishop d4 and once again you are in a
totally drawn endgame where the King can
sit over here and in guard these ponds
and this Bishop can pass back and forth
forever and ever and ever
so of course c3 is the idea for black to
try and hold this position
fortunately though B takes c3 ends up
being just enough for white to to draw
King takes a3 is all you can do and now
who can find the big draw for for white
here
is this actually a draw I'm a
second-guessing myself now I'm
second-guessing myself and my analysis I
was so sure that this one was somehow
drawing I'm not so sure anymore
terrifying stuff
pushing the c-pawn that's what you would
expect I think but Bishop takes say king
d2 then king bee - I'm losing faith I'm
losing faith here
d5 takes we have a check okay and that's
a draw but King b3 is actually just
gonna be a table base win okay let's all
back up here for a second what is going
on I was so sure that this was a draw
but maybe this is just the way to break
the fortress maybe King D 3 is is the
valiant effort that we need here maybe
not though all right
well turns out my analysis was not quite
correct this is just a winning plan for
black unless I'm missing something here
there's no way I think to stop this a
pond from just queening let me just
double-check everything c3 c3 is is good
are there any other choices here no you
have to take King takes a three all
right well it's just gonna be a win here
for uh for black so confirmed Magnus
Carlsen
mr. Wynn with F takes G for at least
confirmed enough for for my eyes here
this idea with c3 is really powerful
prevents white from holding on here so
94 not quite enough it turns out c3 but
killer blow from from blacks so just to
analyze this a little bit further King
takes 83 if you try to bring this Queen
King to the Queen side well now King b3
keeps an eye on everything it's for
example c4 we can even simply take this
pawn gave me four is not gonna be enough
if King d2 then I think King b2 should
be good d5 for example will take if a
check King back to b3 and if you slide
this King over to see one who sees the
the winning move here for black there's
only one move I think that that wins
well one move doesn't blow it but one
move just delays the winning move for
another turn so
who sees the only win here for for black
only one way to win
events the Jeep on mode it doesn't lose
the game or doesn't prevent the win but
yet the idea is of course Bishop c4 if
you advance the Jeep on white takes and
then you have to play Bishop b4 anyways
so so Bishop b4 is the move you need to
prevent this king from getting to a-1
and now this is just going to be a win
we push this pawn off the board yeah we
push this pawn off the board that's
basically it
if you pass with the bishop we will push
push push push push
and then push and the bishop has to
decide between these two pawns if you
try to bring the King back to the Queen
side well now we push push push
King here and Bishop f3 guarding the
pawn king f2 we go here we clean and
then the game ends okay so gonna be a
win for black really killer stuff I had
analyzed this line before and somehow
thought that white could hold on to the
draw but not the case so turns out the
winning plan in this endgame is in fact
to bring this King to the Queen side get
rid of these pawns on the Queen side now
there was a question that I will go over
what about bringing the knight to a 1 I
think the fact is it's just not going to
be enough so this is the line that we
looked at night c2 King and if you play
Knight a 1 instead it's just it's a
little bit too much putting this knight
on a square where it's never going to
leave so Bishop f5 keeps this night
under lock and key and then if you start
passing with the bishop well any number
of moves is actually going to be enough
for a win here bishop f2 even and it's
looking looking devastating King me one
instead there should be three and in
Bishop f4 it's gonna be enough and this
Knight is just simply not playing okay
so we found the win everybody great job
that was a surprise to me as well I had
done literal hours of analysis on this
end game and did not realize that this
line was winning now as for the other
lines there are some other ways to try
to win this endgame I liked the idea of
bringing the bishop in
five here this was an idea I had come up
with myself and tried to make work the
issue is for example after these lines
let's say a for let's say 93 kingi for
night f 1 is going to be White's choice
and then if we start doing this business
well white is going to play the move
Bishop e8 let's say we continue now with
Bishop f6 and simply Knight g3 check and
this is the way that white can set up a
permanent fortress here in this position
with this night on g3 it's more or less
impossible to make any kind of progress
with black and so this in my preparation
was going to be the big point of the
lecture is you can set up a fortress
with this dark sewer blockade this is
how to play when you have a bishop and a
night against the two bishops you try
and create a strong hold on
the color of your bishop because of
course this bishop can never influence
the g3 square and this is the big
drawing idea for white against every
line except the one I just showed where
the King goes straight to the Queen side
and white is helpless to to stop the
pawns in the opposite colored Bishop
endgame so night on g3 there you go this
was originally the big point the new big
point is that this endgame is in fact a
win and that that's just gonna happen
sometimes in these hyper complex
positions now the only thing you can
really try it with black is Bishop e5
trying to trade off these pieces but
this simply does nothing we're just
gonna pass with nine h5 to g3 our night
somewhere and then back to g3 and
there's simply no entrance squares for
this King if you try g3 yourself I will
simply take it and then you're really no
closer to create making any progress for
example try King at five now well I
guess you are kind of getting your king
in but by bringing your King over here
you're sort of leaving behind the entire
Queen side so let's say Knight e3 check
King f4 and h5 check King f3 Knight f6
it should be six for example Knight h7g
four even
and well that gives up this pawn so King
f4 we can even sacrifice the night for
this pawn and go over here and take some
pawns for example King here here here
here
king d2 even and now all of a sudden I
think I've managed to lose this position
with black this pawn runs fast enough
for white to to create counter play okay
so that's the point if you find yourself
trying to set up a fortress like this
against two bishops you want to create a
stronghold on a dark square in this case
or a light square if white had a light
squared bishop instead use these two
pieces against blacks one piece that
could attack these squares in order to
secure the draw so instructive stuff so
turns out F takes G for by black would
have in fact won this game well I was
looking at Bishop e6 first then night of
two and then I've takes g4 turns out
this position I'm claiming now is just a
win with this nice plan of bringing the
Queen the King to the Queen site and
invading over here and before the white
pieces are actually prepared so now
let's take a look and see what happened
in the game rather than all of this
stuff which I think would have been a
lot more interesting Magnus chose this
move f4 and the players all kind of
agree after some analysis that this
position is going to be a draw car
Aachen succeeds in creating a fortress
here and once again he does so by
utilizing the dark squares so let's see
how that actually happens bishop d4 is
played in the game this is the key move
now for Sergei because he needs this
bishop on d4 in order to allow his
Knight to guard from the f2 square so
Bishop d4 Bishop c7 of course if black
captures on d4 after C takes d4 bishop
d5 for example simply Knight f2 and
after king c3 well what's this there's
simply no way for the black King to get
into the
we are guarding every square and have
created a veritable fortress a fortress
ok so instead we have Bishop c7 now
Knight F - Bishop e6 was magnus carlsen
to try in the game and now King f3
Sergei begins the great passing Sergei
has set up his fortress and now all
that's left to do is you know what
magnets through everything he has at it
and hope that it's strong enough to hold
the game magnus tries to this check came
back to e2 Bishop g2 and then with this
configuration of the pieces there are no
entrance squares for the black King on
the Kings side and the reason Magnus
probably went for this is he noticed
that this idea was still going to be in
the position and so that's the only more
or less winning try for Magnus and
that's what he goes for in the game king
d2 king f7 Magnus maneuvers the pieces
around a little bit but the idea he now
gets to is to bring the King over to a4
and the reason this is going to be a
draw for Sergei is the difference here
we looked at this type of idea for white
in the previous line which is guarding
this pawn with the king and the reason
it didn't quite work is because these
bishops could invade on these open
diagonals right the difference now is
that the dark squared bishop is never
able to invade on this diagonal because
the pawns are blocking it so it goes to
show you how easily things can change
how subtle the differences can be
between a drawn position and a a winning
one so King a for now Sergei is happy
with his little fortress Bishop f7 king
c1 Bishop e6 he passes now with king d2
king b3 came back to C 1 Bishop d3 and
now begins
he begins passing with the night instead
a knight Age 3
King a2 now he passes with bishop for a
turn Bishop c5 this should be - a knight
back to f2 has to guard this pawn bishop
f3 and once again he just passes with
the
pieces Magnus eventually tires of the
passing and plays f3 trying once again
now to open up this diagonal to allow
him some winning chances so what do you
think the move is now for Sergei
Kuryakin the move to hold the draw the
move to hold to hold the draw as easily
as possible at least as easily as
possible
is there one more game if we have time
for it I have a couple more games it
looks like we're not gonna get to all of
them but this is is the main event of
the night this was the definitely the
most interesting end game so okay I'm
assuming some people in the chat have it
of course the easiest way to draw now
with white is to play the move Bishop
III you just stop this Bishop from from
coming to f4 and then you really have
nothing to worry about
now if white plays the move Bishop g3
there are a few things we can do
probably simplest is just continue
passing and this endgame is actually
also just going to be a dead drop
opposite colored bishops make this one a
pretty easy draw for for white so Bishop
III doesn't work Bishop f4 doesn't work
so Magnus tries passing with Bishop d7
now King c1 bishop c8 came C to Bishop
d7 king c1 and now Magnus gave up
essentially and just goes ahead and
place the Bishop f4 the last kind of
hurrah for Magnus changing the pawn
structure but after takes and takes this
endgame is just a draw we see King c2
there should be six and both players
pass for a while
now King b3 and white passes with king
b1 instead of course can't quite touch
this night due to the g4 pawn Magnus
escapes with this King back out to the
Kings side but now that Magnus goes to
the Kings side the white king is also
going to be in time to prevent any
invasions over here so King f2 now and
Sergei gives up this pawn but after
Knight d2
these pieces are of course forked but
should be six King f3 King f5 and this
one is a pretty easy draw now and the
players agree to the draw here and
Magnus was was pretty upset by this game
I think in the post in the postgame
conference of course that's where this
quote comes from I don't believe in
fortresses that you may have heard
tossed around by Magnus before I think
it all originated from this game with
Sergey kurakin tenacious defense
and successful fortress against him here
so hopefully you enjoyed this endgame
we do have 17 minutes left so why don't
we take a look at another endgame from
the match one that was slightly more
successful for the world champion there
were only two decisive games in the
match between Carlson and Kuryakin one
in Kuryakin favored one in Carlson's
favor and then of course Carlsen ended
up winning
during the tiebreaks so let's take a
look at that one game Magnus did win
because it was down to some very nice
and game technique as well okay so this
is not the end game this is the end game
class I don't see why it would care
about this because way too many pieces
on the board we're interested in the
endgame okay some queens getting traded
okay and now let's see I'm not quite
ready to call it an endgame just yet
let's see d4 gets played and some pawns
come off the board now e5 okay brick f6
Rick g7 let's call the endgame here this
is kind of the first part I want to
analyze for you guys so this is an
endgame I guess you could argue it's a
queenless middle game where you know
things are still happening but I'm
willing to call this position a a pure
endgame here so with the white pieces
Magnus Carlsen at this point in the
match was actually down a game - Sergei
kurakin Sergei struck first blood a
little bit earlier on so Magnus really
needs a win at some point you know the
rounds are ticking away he definitely
doesn't want to lose the match so he
needs a win at some point and this kind
of seems to be a pretty comfortable
position for white black has a few
weaknesses to account for and so white
is definitely looking to score a full
point here so what can you do with white
to try and stretch the black forces a
little bit thin see what you can do see
what you can do try and come up with
some kind of plan for white here to give
black some more problems to solve
try and give black some more problems
some more problems in this position here
Eddie has one problem here
he already has another problem here but
we need more problems the C 5 squared
looks good for the night
fair enough an astute observation to be
sure
William o joah says b4 I'm at x-gamer
once 93 immediately it's supposed to be
a draw
unless someone blunders king h 3 plus F
3 plus G 4 that's an interesting idea
attack the backward pawns well we're
looking to create more problems for
black of course these two pawns are
already slightly problematic for the
black player
so arch and chess is fun and one sindhu
EJ Manuel want be poor Knight b3 to c5
so Knight be three I don't think is
going to be the most challenging line
for black think the move b6 does a
pretty good job of keeping this guy
under wraps for the moment and then
black has some time to kind of go ahead
and fully equalize now the move f3 is
pretty interesting here with the idea of
going for g4 the problem is you just
sort of leave your rook a little bit a
little bit unhappy here on f4 and now
black is going to have some time to play
move like c5 Knight b3 b6 and start kind
of expanding over here actually so the
movement that's the best for really
giving black immediate problems is in
fact this move you guys are saying it's
the move B 4
I really like this move from Magnus
Carlsen he takes all this space on the
Queen side and insures that does beep on
is going to be a forever weakness this
pawn never going to be able to be
adequately defended whereas with these
other moves
you guys are suggesting well you know
like King h3 even to start f3 to start
it just does allow black this extra time
he needs to set up a more solid
structure over here on the Queen side so
b4 immediately definitely the way to go
now if black dares to play the move b6
and go for a similar structure that I
was just mentioning well the move B
takes a 5 is is gonna be devastating
it's just gonna be devastating here for
black no way really to guard this pawn
Knight c5 check is going to come as well
and this game is busted so kurakin has
to go in for this move a takes b4 now
after eight takes before of course we
want to recapture with the C pawn and
once again black just isn't quite in
time to play this move b6 in this case
now we do have the move rook c1 in
response b6 leaving behind this C pawn
and now with the open C file black has
no way to guard both of these pawns and
this all comes down to the
it's full of two weaknesses as we said
you can argue why it already has two
weaknesses over here but it's really the
weaknesses on opposite sides of the
board that stretched the black pieces
too thin and allowed Magnus Carlsen
to win this game it's all about creating
weaknesses that your opponent can't keep
track of here so with that in mind that
is all to say this pawn now is stuck
kind of permanently on b7 Kuryakin tried
98 in the game forcing this truck back
you know after Knight h6 Magnus simply
continues with the move
a5 and like we said this pawn stuck on
b7 now and this is really how Magnus
secured a permanent advantage in this
endgame so always look for opportunities
like this to take this extra space in
the endgame to give your opponent kind
of permanent weaknesses that they have
to keep track of its these weaknesses on
opposite sides of the board that give
you winning chances so ok Knight f5
played in the game challenging this
Knight
of course we're not interested in
trading knights here so Magnus plays
Knight to b3 King c7 was cariocans
attempt and Magnus just plants this
Knight firmly on the c5 square guarding
while attacking b7 and attacking East 6
and this is kind of the crux of the
position for Magnus this is where all of
his pressure is really coming from here
in the game surrogate tried king b8 and
now we have really achieved two
weaknesses in the position for black to
deal with but we still have to come up
with some way to increase the pressure
so try and find some more ideas where do
you want to position your pieces and
where do you want to break through next
if you have white here take some time to
think about it
so you guys actually all like all of the
ideas you guys were suggesting we're
actually really good but it just comes
down to playing it the right way well I
guess it's pretty obvious playing in the
right order you know with the slower
moves you guys were suggesting it does
allow black this time to break free with
moves like b6 so you need to play kind
of quickly in in some cases to ensure
these weaknesses stay there
William show it says bring your rooks
into the action if only it were that
easy York b3 rook b1 c1 get the rooks on
the a and the B files Billy says rook b
1 and b v 1 says b5 immediately chess is
fun says a 6 rook a3 so the prevailing
idea I do think is rook B 1 and B 5 and
this is eventually the idea that Magnus
is that Magnus uses here to break
through and challenge these pawns just a
little bit more
the problem with a6 is almost always
this move b6 is going to be a little bit
too much for white to deal with king a7
can follow and this pawn on a6 is is
difficult to guard obviously you're
probably assuming you would prep it a
bit more but I do like this idea with b5
a bit better
the reason being with b5 you're opening
one of course this file where the rooks
and to this rank as well and so these
are the problems that are gonna give
black some issues here however I don't
think this on its own is gonna be enough
to actually win so you want to kind of
hint that you're gonna play b5 which is
why Magnus plays rook b1 to start Sergei
Kuryakin simply plays
King a7 now we have rook d3 rook c7 or a
390 for rook back over to d1 this Knight
comes in to f5 and now Magnus does the
really mean thing which is yes he's
hinting that he wants to play moves like
a sixer moves like b5 but now also he
wants to make threats on the Kings side
as well it still comes down to this idea
threats on both sides of the board so
now he plays King age three and after
night age six he plays f3 so now all of
a sudden black has to worry about this
idea of g4 coming and he also has to
worry about these ideas of b5 coming as
well in the game karaoke and tried rook
f7 challenging this F pawn just a little
bit and now Magnus really takes his time
he plays rook d4
but now Knight f5 hits the rook so rook
back to d2 look over to h7 really eyeing
against this g4 idea but now heroic b3
comes rook e to e 7r ooook d2 d3 and now
to rec aid shape by Sergei really just
relegated to passing here now rook could
be won by Magnus and now rook H to H 7
and this is the moment that Magnus
Carlsen chose to break through with b5
perhaps actually a move like King h8 was
slightly more accurate defense
now after b5 there would be C takes me 5
or it takes b5 and Herick c8 and the
game would definitely keep going Magnus
can play the move g4 and now break
through with these threats on the other
side of the board
Sergei might have a little bit better
drunk chances after the move rook H to H
7 now this works e8 ideas simply isn't
there and that was really what black was
relying on to be able to hold this
position
so now b5 breaks through C takes b5 rook
takes b5 and after d4 and rook b6 this
pawn on e6 simply Falls and this is
really the only opportunity
Magnus needed here to break through and
win this position
rook c7 by Sergei tries to get active
but Knight takes c6 is winning a crucial
pot rook c3 Knight back to f4 Eric H to
c7 now night up to d5 is slightly
tactical but good enough for Magnus
Carlsen roof takes d3 Knight takes c7
King over to b8 night be 5 and Magnus
has secured his extra pawn can you see
it comes on the board avoiding any
checkmates on the back rank now though
Rick takes g6
through it takes f3 came back to g2
rook b3 this move is a check
take stakes III now c6 King c7 these
pawns come off the board and in this
simple wreck endgame Magnus is just very
clearly winning rook d5 is the key move
now black must guard this age 5 pawn if
h5 falls then the connected passed pawns
are definitely winning so Rick h6 comes
on the board but now after King f3 King
V 8 this King comes up the board and the
black King is relegated to doing nothing
over here okay Jay King f6 and King g7
is unstoppable when once again rook
takes h5 is winning one keep on too many
if rook g8 white can simply insert your
Chi 5 and then capture keeping this pawn
on the board and hopefully you all would
be able to win this endgame with white
this one's not so hard you just move the
rook out of the way and push these pawns
up one at a time while your opponent is
kind of relegated to doing nothing but
letting me do it so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this end game it was a great one
by Magnus Carlsen keeping up the
pressure and then striking at the the
perfect opportunity and that is the game
that leveled the world championship
match back in 2016 a lot of magnets to
get into those rapid tiebreak playoffs
and secure his title for another two
years hopefully we'll see more
interesting end games like this one in
this year's World Championship match
hopefully there is a world championship
match who really knows but with that in
mind hopefully you guys enjoyed these
end games hopefully you found them as
interesting as I did and hopefully you
learned a little something
now if you're watching live be sure to
head over to the twitch channel where
I'm going to be doing and analyse your
games class if you're watching the video
that's all for me tonight thank you so
much for joining me for this edition of
the endgame class my name is Caleb Denby
and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]